fifth meeting of the cmp-17 and fifth
meeting of the cma4
as we continue the national statements I
would like to remind representatives of
the actions in place to ensure effective
time management namely the three-minute
time limit for statements during the
high level segment
please be reminded that statements
should be as concise and brief as
possible as full texts of the official
statements will be made available on the
UNIF Triple C website
speaking slots for those who are not in
the plenary at the time for delivery of
their statements will be scheduled to
speak at the end of all statements of
the same category
dear distinguished heads of state and
government delegates or a guess let us
begin
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Charles Mitchell president
of the European Council and Her
Excellency Miss Ursula Von derulian
president of the European Commission
foreign
excellencies you have the floor
is
[Music]
foreign
in part facility
message
my name is
University
of solidarity
Elizabeth
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you Excellency
[Applause]
it is my pleasure
to welcome Her Excellency Miss Ursula
Von lerden president of European
commission your Excellency you have the
floor
good afternoon
in February
in the same week that Russia invaded
Ukraine the ipcc issued a stark warning
to the global community
its message could not have been clearer
the climate is changing faster than our
capacity to adapt
so the world must deliver better and
faster
the global fossil fuel crisis must be a
game changer
and my friends
let us not take the highway to hell
let us earn the clean ticket to Heaven
that is our responsibility
and for Europe
the answer is repower is you
we're not just cutting our dependency on
Russian fossil fuels that is good
but that is not enough
but we are massively accelerating the
rollout of Renewables
the European Union's additional
renewable capacity is set to more than
double this year up to 50 gigawatt
and if we accelerate and if we scale up
and that's our plan
we can in the next year meet a new
all-time record of over 100 gigawatt of
additional renewable capacity
because we know that every kilowatt hour
of electricity that we generate from
renewable sources like solar and wind
and green hydrogen is not only good for
our climate but also good for
Independence and our security of supply
and here the global South has the
resources in abundance so let's team up
and that is why the European Union is
signing new hydrogen Partnerships with
Egypt within Namibia with Kazakhstan
that was why we are supporting Partners
such as Vietnam and South Africa to
decarbonize their economies
we need to reach the Paris goals and
Europe is staying the course
we will reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions by at least 55 percent till
2030 and that's cast in law
with our fit for 55 package we're
putting in place the most ambitious
legal framework worldwide and we call on
all major emitters to increase their
ambitious Ambitions too
and in addition
we need tangible progress on our Global
goal for adaptation
those most in need in the developing
world must be supported in adapting to a
harsher climate
and this is also why the cop must make
progress on averting minimizing and
addressing loss and damage from climate
change it is high time to put this on
the agenda
and finally
we urge our partners in the global North
to step up their climate Finance to the
global South
team Europe is providing its fair share
of the 100 billion dollar promise
for the second year in a row we have
exceeded 23 billion euros despite the
covet pandemic despite the Russian war
and a big bug of our climate Finance
goes already to adaptation so it is
doable and we call on others to step up
too my message to you today is Europe is
staying the course so let's do this
journey together thank you so much
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Andrey nirina rajolina
president of Madagascar
your Excellency you have the floor
climatic
president
is
foreign
alipook
in the resolution
Edition
suppose
the planet
or future
the situations
foreign
neutrons
is adaptations
Crema
a vector is Madagascar
um
Humanity
foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr abdulfa Al Boran abdahman
head of the transitional sovereignty
Council of the Republic of Sudan
your Excellency you have the floor
is
foreign
Karim
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
well Mia foreign
foreign
October
is
Almanac
foreign
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Hassan Sheikh Muhammad
president of Somalia
[Applause]
your Excellency you have the floor
alhamdulillah
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
it's an honor and privilege to deliver
the national statement of my country
Somalia at this Council as this crucial
cop 27
in Egypt
I thank Egypt and president abdulsi
Abdul fatah
as well as all other International
partners for bringing us together
in this
for being us together
sorry
to to discuss what can only be described
as the greatest challenge facing our
world today
all the available scientific evidence
across the world clearly
shows that temperatures and sea levels
are rising and droughts and floods are
increasing food security is weak and
climate induced conflict of resources
like water and livestock posture are
common especially in sub-sahara Africa
which is dealing with one of the worst
droughts
in the modern history
the presence of so many leaders in this
meeting today gives me a confidence that
not only is the issue of climate change
being taken seriously internationally
but that during cop 27 genuine plans and
strategies will be negotiated agreed and
implemented quickly to ensure we
mitigate
and adapted to it is costly destructive
effect is across the world
in 2022 over 800 million people majority
from
majority of them from Africa are food
insecure
in Somalia over 7 million people cannot
meet their basic food needs and require
urgent to humanitarian assistance
we need to ask ourselves why are we here
after 26 years
the answer is one and it is climate
change
and conflict
what's evident is that there is no
equity or fairness in global climate
burden sharing because the Nations who
produce the least Greenhouse Green Gas
House Green gases emissions like Somalia
Bay the highest price twice
first
their citizens do not benefit from the
developing nations industrialization and
their own Nations usually have minimum
industrial output or capacity and
secondly
they seldom have the fiscal space
or technology and expertise to respond
to the effects of the climate change
which directly humbris their development
as presidents and citizens health and
well-being
in Somalia we are most vulnerable
to climate change climate change is a
political
security economic challenge for us and
we are taking it very seriously
in this regard we have dedicated a new
ministry and launched a new Somalia
green initiative to address the matter
head on
today Somalia is facing a humanitarian
crisis which we are desperately trying
to respond to because of current drought
we have also
had severe floods which have destroyed
key infrastructure
Prime agricultural land as well as the
livelihoods of entire communities
today's Global Food and energy
insecurity is disproportionately
affecting Somalia because of the impact
of the climate change and our people's
inability to grow their own crops
because of the ongoing drought as a
direct consequency urbanization
and all it is environmental impact are
also on the rise this is not sustainable
unacceptable
climate mitigation and adaptation
strategies and plans need to be rapidly
implemented in Somalia to safeguard the
lives and the livelihood of our most
vulnerable citizens however
this requires real resources including
accessible Grant basic financing and
investment in climate resiliency in key
areas including Water Management
infrastructure and renewable energy this
is vital because many of the developing
nations
at least developing nations like Somalia
are still struggling with the economic
impact of the covid-19 pandemic and a
national debt sustainability issues and
they must not be left behind
furthermore
existing National Regional and
international climate early warning
systems are not only useful where we can
Finance early effective action to
mitigate and adapt quickly
in Somalia we have one of the longest
coasts in the world vast arable land and
we are striving to build an economically
stable future with both benefits from
our strategic location and enormous
natural resources
potential including the blue economy
however
we must take urgent action today to work
with all our International Partners to
ensure we make the climate adaptation
and mitigation Investments that will
make this reality
tomorrow
in this age of global interconnectivity
and interdependency we must not think in
silos or develop developed versus
developing nations because the looming
existential climate disaster does not
care for these distinctions
climate change is complex
and it is going
to match and it's not going to magically
disappear
in this regard we must respond to this
single greatest challenge to the
humanity today
together
and on the theme basis of solidarity
multilateralism
International cooperation is the only
way out
I thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr mechanic president of
your Excellency you have the floor
um
Mr President
Mr executive secretary
excellencies
more than three decades ago
we began this process to stabilize
greenhouse gas to prevent dangerous
climate change
clearly something is not working
as emissions continue to rise
climate Finance remains wholly
inadequate
the 1.5 degree
limit will soon be crossed and the
resulting
climate
Injustice is suffered daily across the
planet
fundamental human rights are being
undermined
every minute of every day across the
planet
our Collective
addiction to fossil fuels are mainly
responsible
excellencies
it is time for this
process to be dealt with effectively
um
we
we must bring additional tool that will
inspire the real State action that is
required
is of the opinion that States have
existing legal obligation that under
a range of international
fundamental laws to protect the rights
of present and future generation from
the adverse impacts of climate change
the unfcc does not
um
it's not intended to operate in
isolation
nor does it absorb the body of the legal
obligation
and the other
treaties they have ratified
Excellence is alongside a global
Coalition of modern
50 50
85 nation is now calling for the
um
uh United Nation to legally reveal
international law from the um for
international court of justice
to help the make
better climate decision
in just a few weeks the general assembly
well
um
will inspire
real action
to save the goals of the Paris agreement
and maintain the Integrity of the
climate change
the international court of justice
process is inclusive
all states are invited to share their
views on how to bring better
understanding
to Legal consistency and coherence to
climate change
strengthen nationally determined
contribution we must
we must strengthen our understanding of
what international law has already
obliged us to do
the in this regard the objective of
another's initiative is to transform the
legal context of which we all act to
protect human rights from climate
climate harm
the time has come to uh for for
international court of justice
to consider climate change our young
people are demanding climate Justice and
in the generational equity
and so I appeal in the strongest terms
to lead us here at Corp 27
um to vote in favor of the icj climate
resolution at the U.N General Assembly
so that we can finally put human rights
under the center of climate decision
I thank you all for your attention God
bless us all
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
foreign
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Michael Martin prime
minister of Ireland
your Excellency you have the flow
excellencies
across the world we are witnessing the
reality of a climate of a changing
climate record temperatures
wildfires floods and droughts
what were once exceptional events are
now occurring with increased frequency
and ferocity
people in the poorest part of our planet
are being driven from regions that can
no longer support and sustain them
climate change is fueling conflict
Global instability competition for
resources and abject human misery
if this generation doesn't step up
urgently future Generations will not
forgive us
As Leaders it is our responsibility to
drive the transformation necessary
in Ireland the government has set
legally binding emission reduction
targets of 51 by 2030 and has committed
Ireland to becoming climate neutral by
2050.
we have fixed sectoral emission ceilings
limiting greenhouse gas emissions for
each economic sector
achieving these targets will be
challenging so we have enacted a legal
framework to guide and underpin our
efforts
the burden of climate change globally is
falling most heavily on those least
responsible for our predicament
Ireland has therefore published an
international climate Finance roadmap
reaffirming our commitment to supporting
the world's most vulnerable people
we are more than doubling our finance to
at least 225 million a year by 2025.
we will not see the change we need
without climate Justice
I am therefore pleased to announce that
Ireland will contribute 10 million to
the global Shield Initiative for 2023 to
take the most vulnerable from climate
loss and damage
As Leaders we must lead
our citizens will become increasingly
cynical wary and hopeless if Wards are
not urgently matched by Deeds if
commitments do not generate new
realities
we can already see and feel the world
around us changing
temperatures in Ireland have been so
mild this Autumn that trees are
producing a new growth before they have
even shed their leaves
the situation is urgent but it is not
hopeless
as the U.N report shows we are bending
the curve of emissions downwards
last year's U.N projections showed
emissions continuing to rise Beyond
2030. this year however analysis shows
them no longer Rising after that date
it is progress but it is far from enough
our Collective commitments as notified
would still see temperatures increase by
2.5 degrees by the end of the century
with devastating consequences for the
sustainability of our planet we need to
do more
when I spoke at cop 26 last year I said
I did not believe that it is now too
late that that the transition will be
too costly that it is inevitable that we
will leave people behind I believe it
even more so now it is realistic for our
Legacy to be a sustainable Planet a
world alive with an abundance of plant
and animal life with cleaner water and
healthier air with livable cities and
sustainable rural communities we in
Ireland will do everything in our power
to bring it about this generation of
leaders cannot say that we didn't know
the science is clear
every ton of carbon warms the world
every delay makes our task that bit
bigger let us not waste a second more
thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
well
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Patrick fiala prime
minister of
your excellently you have the flow
thank you Mr President excellencies
ladies and gentlemen let me express my
appreciation to the government and
people of the Arab Republic of Egypt for
hosting this important conference we
reward leaders Gathering here in Sharma
Sheikh see the urgency of our response
to climate change which affects the
well-being of mankind my country is
currently is currently holding the
presidency of the Council of the
European Union from this position I
would like to stress that we are dealing
with the unprecedented aggression of
Russia against Ukraine besides a direct
impact it has many tragic side effects
such as an energy and food crisis
affecting many nations and also huge
negative effects on the environment and
climate protection
remaining faithful to the Paris
agreement commitments many countries in
Europe are now forced to use more fossil
fuels than expected
they do that to have enough energy to
keep their people warm we understand the
social and economic aspects of the
situation
the EU reacted to work quickly and
created the Revolutionary power EU
package
it is a way out of this crisis it will
reduce our dependence on Russian gas and
also on fossil fuels in general
this is important because we must not
lose our focus on the ongoing climate
change which poses critical threat to
many
scope of climate change requires our
joint efforts
the EU climate ambition has always been
very high and even today we stand ready
to go on the rules of the Paris
agreement the achievements of previous
conferences like katowitz Madrid and
Glasgow must be translated into concrete
actions the Czech Republic is fully
committed to the EU joint climate goals
to reduce greenhouse gas emission at
least by 55 percent by
2030 and to reach the climate neutrality
by 2050.
presiding over the EU Council we are
working on the finalization of the fit
455 package it is it is a key
legislative legislative framework for
achieving our goals and it's completely
in line with the national determinate
contribution stipulated by the Paris
agreement
both packages fit 455 and re-power EU
will help us enhance Energy Efficiency
and speed up the clean energy transition
another topic brought forward under the
Czech EU presidency is the disaster risk
reduction and adaptation to enhance
climate Security in fragile context
the Prague appeal has summarized
principles and lessons land for
adaptation and reduction of loss and
damage caused by climate change we've
also repeatedly contribute to the United
Nations office for disaster risk
reduction work on early warning and
early action the goal is simple to
prevent and minimize losses and damages
caused by climate change
the adaptation to climate change is also
the Cornerstone of the Czech climate
policy we are focusing on appropriate
adaptation capacity while fostering our
climate resilience
my government plans to face out coal for
casting on renewable and nuclear energy
and maximizing Energy Efficiency and
savings
and they keep our promises by 2020 the
Czech Republic reduced greenhouse gas
emissioned by 43 percent compared to
1990 a number well beyond our commitment
coping with the climate change is not
only about domestic measures we also
need to assist other countries and
regions
the most vulnerable developing countries
need to help with strengthening their
climate action and dealing with damage
and I am glad that the Czech Republic is
going to have its share in the
international support
in this spiritual government decided to
remove our contribution to the green
climate fund into which we will be
contributing 1 million euros starting
from 2024.
excellencies ladies and gentlemen to
implement efficient climate policy we
need to keep building strong partnership
on all levels and across all sectors we
need to work together on finding
realistic and fair solutions that will
help us overcome Global Climate
challenges by reducing emissions
adaptation Innovation and Joint
strategies this is our common task we
all need to take it seriously in order
to provide a better future for Next
Generation thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Muhammad I am
prime minister of the State of Palestine
your Excellency you have the flow
said there is
philbidaya
is
Allah
say that was
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
sannian
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
philistine
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Kasia nathano prime
minister of tuvalu
your Excellency you have the flow
Mr President
distinguished delegates ladies and
gentlemen
let me thank you for your attitude
leadership in guiding our 27 Conference
of parties business
and wish you and your team success in
our work and outcomes
let me also take this opportunity to
thank the government and the people of
Egypt
our gracious hosts for their preparation
and hospitalities
extended to me in my delegation
each cup Mr President tuvalu is ever so
encouraged
by the good intention and good will
pronounce and announce through countries
beautiful
beautifully crafted speeches made in
these institutions
as well as in other platforms the world
over
but this said Mr President we must
always gauge our efforts
by what is happening to our environments
and to the people who were affected in
the front line
as we reflect back to the transformative
Spirit of our agenda 2030
which is almost in its halfway stage
we recall in 2015
that the 2030 agenda and visited the
world of universal respect
for human rights and human dignity
the rule of law
Justice equality and non-discrimination
of respect for race
ethnicity and cultural diversity
and of equal opportunity permitting the
full realization of human potential and
contributing to Shared prosperity
Mr President
to Value his proactively seeking
Solutions and not sitting on its roles
by any imagination
we are developing a long-term adaptation
plan known as the ltap de lafina
which is informed by science
experience and best practices
lovinga is an ambitious plan and wishes
to save to value
to accommodate our entire population
safely Beyond worst case sea level rise
Beyond 2100s
and to offer solutions to pre-existing
developments and resource constraints
issues that have remained difficult to
tackle for decades
and to offer hope for the future of
tuvalu and to valuence
so president tuvalu as the Pacific
Region's Champion for loss and damage
it's an outcome of cop 27. that delivers
a secure
guaranteed loss and damage financing
facility
especially considering the urgency
caused by climate change impacts as we
iterated by
ipcc reports
Mr President the existing gaps in the
legal infrastructure for dealing with
climate change must also be addressed
to follow an anticoa and papuda have
established courses a commission of
small island States on climate change
and international law
to seek advisory opinions from the
international Tribunal for the law of
the sea particularly on the Endeavors to
clarify stage International legal
obligation
to combat climate change effects
as sea level rise
our population will be displaced from
their homes however climate change
climate refugees is not covered
under the categories of the refugee
convention
drowning islands and flooded Nations
requires a reassessment of our basic
human rights
to value and muscle Islands have
established a rushing Nation initiative
to commit the International Community
to preserving our sovereignty and basic
human rights
these include the entire the rights to
Life Health
food and water
livelihoods cultural privacy and home
and life and property
Mr President we all know that the
leading cause of climate crisis is
fossil fuels
and other nations
calling for a fossil fuels
non-proliferation treaty to steer our
developments models to peruse Renewables
and just transition away from 40 fields
today's climate emergency can be reduced
to two basic concepts
time and temperature
it's getting too hot and there is very
time to slow and reverse the increasing
temperature
therefore it is essential to prioritize
fast acting strategies that avoid the
most warming
based on time we have already reached
1.1 degrees by temperature the planet is
hitting this proportionately where most
seats are situated
salt leave pollutants deliver fast
results
scientific research confirms that
decarbonization alone does not slow
near-term warming
CO2 must be paired with deep cuts to the
sword leave climate super pollutions
like methane
black carbon hydrofluorocarpons and
ground level ozone
Mr President these are our resources in
our ltap
lafina which is homegrown strategy
backed up by science
one that is more durable and sustainable
in our views
we are willing to share to all
like-minded Partners including Republic
of China Taiwan
whose meaningful participation in the
U.N specialized agencies including who I
call and UNF Triple C is the global
fight
against climate change should be
applauded and recognized
Mr President if we do not make Headway
in this cup to always quickly losing
faith in the institution to deliver a
sustainable outcome that does not leave
Island communities and many of us behind
nevertheless I remain positively
optimistic in our institutions and
Global Community to deliver
but the ipcc reports are science-based
in their narrative is clear and honest
and may I say saw also the experiences
and realities of my country is implied
to value and many islands are struggling
to cope with sea level rise that
exacerbates
many other development challenges
I thank you for this opportunity in
which cop 27 all success to Value
Modesto
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Robert Abella prime
minister of Malta
your Excellency you have the floor thank
you Mr chair
excellencies
distinguished guests
dear friends
as world leaders and policy makers
we need to keep asking ourselves one
fundamental question how significant is
our contribution to slowing down climate
change
coming from one of the smaller Nations
and an island state
we have recognized that implementing
change however small or minute of our
contribution is crucial for succeeding
in the goal of addressing climate change
a reduction in the concentration of
carbon in our atmosphere and the
lowering of global temperatures require
two things commitment
and ambition
our presence at cop year after year is a
manifestation of our commitment to the
Paris principles as well as our resolve
to keeping the 1.5 degree Target alive
now we must move Beyond
statements of Goodwill are indeed
important however
it is concrete action that will deliver
results
our actions or inaction is what will
Define our relationship with the planet
at this moment this relationship is
fragile so much so I dare say that this
climate crisis is indeed a threat to our
Global Security
countries all over the world are being
battered by climatic extremes
from rising sea levels to devastating
storms from drought
two floods
from excessive Heat to water scarcity
it is also no secret that smaller States
especially islands like my country Malta
and other vulnerable countries are
paying the higher price even though we
are the ones that have least contributed
to the release of carbon throughout
through the combustion of fuel of fossil
fuels over the years
so going forward the future that we want
to create should be based on the
equality of Nations without any
distinction
if we want to aim for success in
mitigating climate change we must
recognize the differentiated impact it
has especially upon the most vulnerable
having said all this however it is also
true that our small size can be used to
our advantage for us this is an
existential threat and our industry has
to be Innovative in The Way It prepares
itself for the years ahead
we do not have the scale nor perhaps the
capacity to develop new technologies to
make a difference globally however
we are probably the best place to serve
as a test bet for them
as part of the ambitious gag emission
Reduction Program being the eu's fit 455
package Malta my country is willing to
do its part we are confident that the
actions which we are implementing as
part of our low carbon development
strategy will indeed lead us to climate
neutrality by 2050. resolve climate
discipline and sound fiscal and monetary
policies coupled with investments in
digitalization robust energy policies
electrification and Renewables will get
us where we need to be simultaneously we
also recognize that we need to help
others and we are doing this through
action and the following ways firstly by
supporting countries experiencing
climate-related disasters by way of
example one example this last week the
Maltese government
send substantial medical assistance to
Pakistan following the devastating
floods secondly
through assistance for others in their
part towards the carbonization
last year in Glasgow I had announced the
island for Islands initiative expressing
malta's willingness to provide
assistance to small island developing
states with whom we share comment common
climate predicaments through this
initiative utilizing our experience in
water management we are providing
technical assistance to Islands like us
for enhanced resource use greater return
on investments and more resilience to
climate-induced scar cities
this year my government has also focused
on a structured dialogue with the
relevant stakeholders with the private
sector and this has generated a crucial
momentum to drive the green and just
transition and
our efforts will indeed continue
discussing our experiences the lessons
learned and the options for a
decarbonized economy are Central to this
initiative and we wish to share indeed
further with small island developing
States
to enhance capacity building we shall be
providing scholarships to students
coming from other Islands to undertake
climate related studies at the
University of Malta moreover I am proud
to announce that as we already did last
year Malta we will be doubling its
contribution to the international
climate fund through contributions to
this fund further work will be actioned
around the world finally
I would like to underline a point about
our ocean and cryosphere
sea level rises caused by climate change
should not affect any rights which
islands and coastal regions currently
have over their land and Maritime
jurisdiction
dear friends allow me to reiterate the
appeal conveyed by many colleagues
leaders change makers and youths let us
lead our generation's Revolution like
our forefathers dead before us
the Green Revolution will lead to Great
benefits affordable clean energy
healthier and enough food for all
let us be ambitious let us be committed
let us do this for our people let us
deliver
for our future thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Philip Davis prime
minister of Bahamas
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you very much
your excellencies
some bahamians have asked
why have we come here
I say
that you have come because we have to
believe that a safer better future is
possible
I say that we have come because we
believe that action
Rel considered action can save the
planet and save our human race
and I see that we have come because each
Nation here
acting in its own enlightened
self-interest knows in a most profound
way that we need each other
to make this work
I live
in the most beautiful country on Earth
but right now
even as I speak
bahamians are mobilizing to prepare for
the impact of yet another powerful storm
a tropical storm Nicole
so I come here with a simple request
let's get real
what we need most at this conference is
to confront the radical truth
big ambitious goals are important
but not if we use aspirations to obscure
reality
a goal to limit global warming to 1.5
degrees is on life support
this is a hard Truth for many to admit
because even the best case scenarios
will mean almost unimaginable upheaval
and tragedy
the reality is of War
economic headwinds
The Hangover from the pandemic
and competition among world powers
cannot be used as justification not to
confront these imminent dangers
let's get real it's only going to get
worse
we are entering a new climate era that
will drive extreme geopolitical and
economic instability
statements without binding commitments
or enforcement mechanisms have been used
again and again as a way to postpone
real action
yes
the world's wealthiest carbon polluters
should pay for the very extensive loss
and damage caused by their emissions but
getting real means understanding that
it'll be self-interest that drives
decision makers
so
I'm not here to ask any of you to love
the people of my country with the same
passion as I do or even to act on behalf
of future Generations in your own
country
I'm asking
what is it worth to you
to prevent millions of climate refugees
from turning into tens of millions and
then hundreds of millions putting
pressure on borders and security and
political systems
across the world
I'm not telling you to overhaul the
World Bank for this new climate era
because it is the right thing to do I'm
telling you to get smart and act quickly
to address the synthesis systemic risk
of climate change
multilateral Banks must play a crucial
role in scaling up financing options
that will provide real solutions
I'm not here to tell the private sector
they give up caring about profits I'm
here to say that in a world of profound
instability your profits are very much
in danger so we need to work together to
transition the world to clean energy
let's get real
about what's coming let's get real about
what we need to do next
most of us in the Bahamas
are descendant from people who are
forcibly removed from their homes
Shackled In the bottom of boots and
shipped across the Atlantic
we are the children of the survivors of
that man-made tragedy
we inherit their moral imperative
we have a duty to fight for our survival
as they fought so desperately for theirs
so even as we have urged the world to
act we have not made it we know we are
what it takes to provide a kind of
leadership and Innovation that
contribute to meaningful Solutions
our mangroves seagrasses and soil
marshes are a critical carbon sink
While others were talking we took action
and passed Innovative new legislation
that deals with low carbon we created a
regulatory framework for dealing and
trading in carbon credits other
countries are already considering
adopting our model
just this past Sunday
we agreed in principle with the IMF to
partner together among other things to
determine how carbon credits can be used
productively as a new asset class
yes
this is what real life-changing action
looks like
we're in the Bahamas are not sitting
still
will not flinch from confronting the
hard truths
we'll continue to offer our leadership
and we will continue our drive for
Innovation and ingenuity
whoever you are wherever you are bring
your climate solutions to the Bahamas
help us convert our Frontline
vulnerabilities into cutting-edge
solutions for all
because we refuse to lose hope
we will not give up
we have no other choice
the alternative compels us to present
ourselves at your borders as refugees
the alternative consigns us to a watery
grave
the alternative will erase erase us from
history
This Is Why We Fight
we will continue to lift up our heads
towards the Rising Sun
we'll continue to march on we will
continue to believe that it is safer
better future is possible because
because
all our lives
all our lives depend on it
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr kriyakos mitsutakis
Prime Minister of Greece
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you
thank you chair
excellencies uh dear colleagues uh
ladies and gentlemen
we meet today here in Sharma Sheikh
during an acute energy crisis
sparked by Russia's unprovoked war on
Ukraine
and today I want to speak to you as a
radical realist
radical
because I deeply believe in the energy
transition
it is imperative
it is unavoidable
the energy transition is not just about
mitigating risk
it's an opportunity
it is also a strategic necessity
low carbon energy
means energy security
this much is clear
no one can shut down our wind or our sun
energy
but this energy transition will also
allow us to reconceptualize Greece's
economic model
for decades we have been a net energy
importer
our trade balance and our
competitiveness have suffered
this is changing
our future competitiveness will be
grounded on abundant wind and solar
resources
Greece is already a leader in renewable
energy
almost half of our electricity today
comes from wind solar and water
we have more than 10 gigawatts of
installed solar and wind power
and we rank in the top 10 countries of
the world in terms of the penetration of
wind and solar
just a month ago we reached a major
milestone
when for five hours on a sunny and windy
day in October solar and wind met 100
percent of our electricity needs
meanwhile our coal consumption has
fallen by almost 80 percent in less than
10 years
the energy we consume today
emits 30 percent less CO2 than it did in
2005. and we're just getting started
we have just voted our first ever
climate law
committing to carbon neutrality by 2050.
we want to double our renewable capacity
by the end of the decade
we want to be a net electricity exporter
to the rest of Europe
we want to help carry energy and
hydrogen from North Africa and the
Middle East to Europe
we're discussing with Egypt about
building a three gigawatt cable to bring
cheap solar electricity from North
Africa to Europe
we intend to be at the center of a new
Corridor that will redraw the map of
energy in Europe
but at the same time we must also manage
today's crisis
without energy security
there is no energy transition
like many other countries we need to
briefly increase our lignite production
at the same time we need to import more
LNG
and we are investing in our gas
infrastructure in order to enhance our
energy security as well as that of our
neighbors and at the same time we need
to keep supporting our citizens in order
to tackle the adverse consequences of a
profound cost of living crisis
personally I see no tension between
safeguarding the present and investing
in the future
our people will not support us otherwise
that is why I believe that we need
radicalism as well as realism I believe
this is the only way forward and this is
my message to you today thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Eminence Cardinal Mr Pietro perolin
Secretary of State of the Holy See
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you Mr chair
Mr President
ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of Pope Francis
I extend accordion greeting to all of
you
and wish to assure you of his closeness
support and encouragement
as you work diligently towards a
fruitful outcome of this conference
a few days ago in Bahrain he emphasized
the hope that cop 27th will be a step
forward for concrete and farsighted
choices
undertaken with the younger generation
in mind before it is too late and our
futures is compromised
this is the first unfcc CCA successions
to which the Holy See participates as a
state party to both the convention and
the Paris agreement
this important step is consistent with
Pope Francis announcement in 2020 that
the Holy See would commit to the goal of
NATO zero emissions responding at two
levels first the Vatican city-state he
committed to reducing net emissions to
zero before 2050.
through intensifying its efforts to
improve its Environmental Management
efforts that have already been in place
for a number of years
and second the Holy See is dedicated to
promoting education in integral ecology
indeed political Technical and
operational measures are not enough
they must be combined with an
educational approach that promotes new
Lifestyles while fostering A Renewed
pattern of development and
sustainability based on care fraternity
and cooperation as humankind and on the
straightening of the Covenant between
the human beings and the environment
Mr President the social ecological
crisis that we are living is a
propitious moment for individual and
Collective conversion
and for concrete decision that can not
longer be postponed
the human face of the climate emergency
challenges us deeply
we have a moral duty to occur concretely
in order to prevent and respond to the
always more frequent and severe
humanitarian impacts caused by the
climate change
the growing phenomenon of migrants being
displaced by it is a concerning sign
even when they lack accessor to
International protections
States cannot live without tangible
Solutions
including in the areas of the adaptation
mitigation and resilience
where this is not possible it is
important to recognize migration as a
form of adaptation and to increase the
availability and flexibility of pathway
for regular migration
warningly we must admit that Global
events like a covid-19 and the
increasing number of conflicts all over
the world with their serious ethical
social and economic consequences
risk undermining Global Security
exacerbating food insecurity
jeopardizing multilateralism and even
overshadowing our efforts here in charm
and Sheikh
we cannot allow for this to happen
climate change will not wait for us
our world is now far too
interdependent and cannot permit itself
to be structured into unsustainable
isolated blocks of countries
this is a time for international and
intergenerational solidarity
we need to be responsible courageous and
forward-looking not just for ourselves
but for our children
last year at cop 26 in Glasgow Pope
Francis sent a message in which he
stressed that the wounds inflicted on
our human family by the covid-19
pandemic and the phenomenon of climate
change are comparable to those resulting
for a global conflict
now this message takes on even more
significance our political will should
be guided by the awareness that either
we win together or we lose together
we must admit that the road to achieving
the objectives of the Paris agreement is
complex in that we have less and less
time available to correct course
27 provides us with a further
opportunity which cannot be wasted
it is an opportunity and was a challenge
to seriously tackle the four pillars of
Paris agreement mitigation adaptation
finance and loss and damage
these four pillars are interconnected
and are a matter of fairness Justice and
equity
we should also not neglect the
non-economic side of loss and damage
like loss of Heritage and cultures here
we have a lot to learn from indigenous
peoples
by acceding to the convention and the
Paris agreement The Odyssey is even more
committed to moving forward on this
journey together
for the common good of human or humanity
and especially on behalf of your
of our youth who are looking to us to
care for present and future Generations
thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Alexander D crew Prime
Minister of Belgium
your Excellency you have the floor
Mr President excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
let there be no doubt
the fight against climate change is a
fight for survival
for our physical survival
but also a fight to keep the social
cohesion
some people feel the consequences of
climate change much harder than others
and some people will feel the
consequences of climate policy much
harder than others
I'm thinking of our farmers of people
who rent an old apartment but also about
small family businesses for instance
so there is it is more important than
ever to get this fight right
the last thing we need now in the fight
against climate change is more
polarization
on one extreme we see the complete
denial of man-made global warming
these people are sticking their heads in
the sand
while on the other side The Other
Extreme we see movements that are
trashing buildings and trashing works of
art
don't get me wrong
I hear and understand the anxiety of
people who are afraid we do not do
enough
and I can reassure them we will do more
more climate investment more
International financing
but I also hear the ones who are at
their wit's end
the ones who fear the personal burden of
climate policy
what we need today are solutions that
work for everyone
yes
we need to be more ambitious
but we also need to take care of people
should leave no one behind
and just like we don't need more
polarization we should also avoid
resignation
because people should know that today
climate's Technologies are more
promising than ever
Belgium comes to this cup with a sizable
private sector delegation
because they bring big solutions to the
table
from offshore wind technology to Green
hydrogen to projects that will not only
protect us against rising sea levels
that can even turn the driest desert
into an oasis again
and the really great news is every
country is doing so
bringing their own Solutions bringing
their own strengths to the table
that is how we reinforce each other
that is how we stop climate change
together
north and south and that is what this
Summit should be about about connecting
expertise with financing and ambition
and we are making Quantum leaps in our
climate policies as well
just look at last year
from repower EU to the inflation
reduction act in America
policy is catching up policy is speeding
up
so my message here today
especially to young people is be part of
the solution
we need you
go study science and above all build
coalitions build Partnerships reach out
to people with different ideas because
that is the moment when Real Change is
happening
and young people notice
the media loves to shine a light on
those who destroy art or shout slogans
like stop oil
but yesterday I met a large allegation
of young Belgian activists who know that
they have to look beyond the slogans
young people who understand that only
meaningful action can replace that oil
young people who know that governments
cannot do this alone
that progress is not imposed top-down
but co-created between partners between
governments and a private sector between
companies and Civil Society
that is the only way forward not by
throwing paint at each other but by
reaching out one to another
this must be our lesson in the fight
against climate change we need to keep
everyone on board
we need to be ambitious and at the same
time we need to be caring
the solutions they're out there
but that does not mean that the
solutions will always be simple
in the words of the late Queen Elizabeth
it has always been easy to destroy
to build and to cherish is much more
difficult
the task ahead is not an easy one but I
am convinced that Humanity can succeed
once more I thank you
thank you your Excellency
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Mark Brown
prime minister of the Cook Islands
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you chair Mr President fellow
leaders excellencies
kirana to you all
foreign
the literal translation of these words
is
when Land Is Lost
man has nothing to stand on
but in the language of my people this
means so much more
my country is 2 million square
kilometers in area
but it is
99.99 ocean
that is why the small islands that
provide my people a place to stand on
are so very important to us
I thank you president CeCe for bringing
us all together in your beautiful city
of sham El Sheikh to discuss exactly
what we stand to lose
just one year ago world leaders came
together in Glasgow and agreed the
Glasgow climate Pact
we committed to keeping the 1.5 degree
goal alive and to thrive and agree to a
course of action to do so
I therefore share the grave concerns
voiced by other small island States
at the findings in the recent NDC
synthesis report
which indicates that our current ndcs
have put us on a 2.7 degree pathway by
20 20 by 2100.
this is based on the pledges that
countries have made
this is the extent of our current Global
Climate ambition
it is clearly not enough
even more concerning is the recent ipcc
report with the science telling us that
if Global emissions do not Peak before
2025
if our current 2.7 degree NDC pledges
are not implemented and that if we stay
the course of the current emissions
trajectory we will face a world with a
median global warming of 3.2 degrees by
2100.
the change is happening already
it is incremental it is Insidious and it
is now becoming inevitable
Mr President for small island states
such as the Cook Islands a small country
made up of 15 islands in the South
Pacific Ocean we cannot underscore how
grave the threat is we are currently
facing
at the national level we are walking the
talk we have converted 13 of our Islands
to solar energy and we have set a target
of 2025 for the remaining two
we have committed to net zero emissions
by 2040.
we have over a number of years built
climate resilient infrastructure as a
matter of survival
despite High construction costs and poor
delivery by climate Finance mechanisms
we have for years implored for enhanced
direct financing to communities for
adaptation
the release of adaptation funding to our
community to our countries needs to be
accelerated and needs to be simplified
next year the Cook Islands will host the
Pacific's Premier political Forum
bringing together the leaders of the
Pacific Nations to discuss Regional
priorities
climate change will be at the Forefront
of these discussions
and we will advocate for tangible fit
for Pacific solutions to address the
climate threat our Blue Pacific
continent faces
each of us in the Pacific individually
and collectively will do what we can to
safeguard our futures
as a collective our Pacific region
contributes less than
0.03 percent to Global emissions
our emissions are the equivalent of a
burning Matchstick in a forest fire
while we are doing our bit on mitigation
efforts and reducing our emissions
there is only so much impact
our national and Regional actions can
have
it is up to the G20 countries
responsible for 80 percent of global
emissions
that we are beholden to for our survival
our survival is being held to Ransom at
the cost of profit and an unwillingness
to act despite the ability to do so
so let me respond in particular to calls
for a moratorium on our oceans
do not tell me to ignore the potential
for promoting the energy transition by
not exploring these much needed minerals
for the Green Revolution that sit in my
ocean
some of us have taken years to gain a
better understanding of how our ocean
resources will save our country and also
help the planet
many of our Pacific cultures
have an embedded culture of conservation
and and Environmental Protection far
better than those countries calling for
a moratorium who continue to emit carbon
at thousands of times the rate that we
do
the very countries that have destroyed
our planet through Decades of
profit-driven development and who to
this day continue through their
profit-driven actions to neglect their
climate change responsibilities making
demands for a moratorium on our Ocean or
worse by providing financing mechanisms
that increase our debt or even swap our
debt for our precious forests and oceans
it is patronizing and it implies that we
are too dumb or too greedy to know what
we are doing in our ocean
we know what we are doing
to protect ourselves and to protect our
ocean
because so far
we are not getting what we need from
those who are damaging the planet
instead those developed countries and
members of the G20 calling for a
moratorium on the oceans need to step up
and meet their climate action
responsibilities and they need to lead
an overall of the unfair and outdated
Global Finance System including climate
financing
Mr President
we support the need to urgently scale up
Global mitigation ambition and agree to
a work program that veers us from our
current emissions trajectory
and which keeps the spirit of the Paris
agreement alive
we further support the urgent need for
developed countries to deliver on their
climate Finance commitments and and for
that Finance to respond to the loss and
damage that is already happening in
climate vulnerable countries and that
will continue to occur in the face of
the projected 3.2 degree temperature
rise
cup 27 is the cup of implementation
the time for Action is now
we cannot afford to be complacent while
homes are being destroyed people are
being displaced and lives are being lost
the effects of climate change is already
eroding the land that my people stand on
we must act now before it is too late I
thank you very much
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Andrei plankovic prime
minister of Croatia
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you very much Mr President
let me at the outset thank our hosts the
Egyptian government and president CeCe
for a warm welcome which we all received
here in sharmil Sheikh
last year in Glasgow we promised to do
everything to accelerate our fight
against climate change it and its
devastating effects
meanwhile the Russian aggression
against Ukraine has confirmed the green
transition is even more important to
increase our resilience
economic losses due to extreme weather
conditions and weather events are
alarmingly increasing
over the last decade my country Croatia
suffered an average annual loss of 0.5
percent of its GDP
our citizens have truly become aware of
the need to mitigate the effects of
climate change more than 80 percent of
them believe that we should act to
prevent harmful harmful consequences for
people and the environment
thanks to New National and European
legislation
we have further accelerated the
transition to low carbon energy in which
Croatia is already well above the EU
average
indeed two-thirds of our electricity and
energy production come from renewable
sources
which also provide one-third of our
total final energy consumption
in order to give a strong impetus to the
solarization of our roofs we have
abolished the vat on solar panels
geothermal energy also represents our
great Potential from heating to
agriculture
Croatia along with Slovenia and Italy is
participating in the north Adriatic
hydrogen Valley Project aimed at
producing green hydrogen
we are also investing significant
efforts in the decarbonization of the
transport sector over the next decade we
will invest more than 4 billion euros in
the modernization of the railways by
2032 we will introduce a fleet of
battery electric cars electric trains to
replace diesel trains
Croatia is an increasingly popular
destination renowned for its unspoiled
nature we promote sustainable tourism
and accommodation facilities with local
and ecologically certified food
production
thanks to a targeted campaign in hotels
and campsites we reduced food waste by
10 percent in just one year over the
past five years Creations have increased
their recycling rate by a third and
reduce the waste disposal rate by a
quarter
ladies and gentlemen in Europe
this summer was the hottest since the
first methodology methodological records
alas scientists warned that it could
also be one of the coldest of all
summers to come
for the first time in history the
Adriatic Sea had warned warmed to a
record 30 degrees Celsius as early as
June an unprecedented drought has caused
300 million euros in damage to our
agriculture in Croatia alone over 13 000
fires devastated an area more than twice
the size of last year
however we have extended reforestation
to our cities where we fund Urban Tree
planning
planting adapting all sectors to extreme
weather condition is key to preventing
and minimizing loss and damage
we support discussions at this cop which
is taking place on a particularly
vulnerable continent to find adequate
solutions to strengthen the resilience
of our communities
dear colleagues to instigate change we
must start with ourselves we have
calculated the carbon footprint of the
Croatian government building in order to
reduce it as symbolic as that may sound
every step counts today's awareness
among our fellow citizens a real
transition also requires close
cooperation between policy makers and
scientists but also relevant data timely
models and a series of concrete measures
that can be implemented by decision
makers at all levels
therefore Croatia will establish a
national Center for climate and
ecological transition as a center of
expertise for all stakeholders
because nature is our best ally in each
of our actions let's prioritize
nature-based Solutions first
ladies and gentlemen since we last met
the world has changed irrevocably
however the scientific data remains
clear and unquestionable we are
witnessing an intolerable imbalance in
Greenhouse emissions that richest one
percent are responsible for 15 percent
of emissions twice as much as the
poorest half of humanity this is unfair
and unsustainable
if we are to win this battle those who
emit the most must do much more and act
urgently especially we in the developed
world this is not just a matter of moral
fairness and solidarity but it is also a
rational necessity nonetheless all
together
large and small states we must act
according to our capacities despite the
current geopolitical upheavals and the
related food and energy crisis at a time
when oil and gas are weaponized we need
to build Partnerships anchored in shared
values including energy and climate
goals and polar resources and
infrastructure to be more resilient
although we are currently facing
economic headwinds we must remain
committed more than ever to implementing
the green transition if our countries
are to benefit from it we simply cannot
allow for today's crisis to turn into
future disasters it is up to all of us
and together to make sure that this does
not happen thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency
prime minister of Pakistan
your Excellency you have the floor
you very much
Mr President
excellent cheese
ladies and gentlemen
assalamualaikum
and a very good afternoon
at the outset I'd like to comment
president Abdul Fazal sisi
for his wonderful leadership
hospitality
in hosting this
cop 27
and the world leaders Summit
to me and my country
this cop
Rings an alarm Bell for Humanity
it is the only platform
where the survival of the human race
as a goal still holds promise
it is also the Forum
where we as vulnerable countries
take our case to the rich
and the resource to build common
purposeful Justice
carbon neutrality and road map
to crucial policy resets
needed in a world
that is burning up faster
than our capacity for recovery
excellencies
I'm sure
all of you must have heard
about the
catastrophic floods in Pakistan
which impacted
33 million people
the size of three European countries
more than half a woman and children
despite
seven times the average of extreme rain
in the south
we struggled on as Raging torrents
from our melting glaciers in the North
ripped out over 8 000
kilometers of metal roads
damaged more than three thousand
kilometers of Railway track
and washed away
standing crop
on four million Acres
and
ravaged
all the four Nook and corners of
Pakistan
an estimate of damage and loss
has exceeded 30 billion dollars
and this all happened despite our very
low
carbon footprints
and yet
we became a victim of
something
with which we had nothing to do
and of course
it was a man-made disaster
Mr President the priorities of Pakistan
have never been
clearer first the global goal on
adaptation needs to be prioritized both
in terms of financing and timelines
we are yet to see the promised
half and half balance in adaptation and
mitigation Finance
the current financing Gap
is too high to sustain any real recovery
needs of those
on the front lines of climate
catastrophe
second
loss and damage needs to be part of the
core agenda of cop 27 to meet the
pressing humanitarian needs of those
that are trapped in a crisis of public
financing
fueled by debt and yet have to fund
climate disasters on their own
this is simply unjust and unfair
say the least
third Mr President climate Finance must
be clearly defined
as new
additional and sustained Resources with
a transparent mechanism that meets the
needs of developing and vulnerable
countries with the speed and scale that
is required
there should now be total clarity
on what actually counts as climate
transfer and what counts as development
fines
for instance as they often overlap
excellencies we have been take talking
for years
but have failed to even agree on the
basics
pledges made at the Copenhagen cop 15 in
2009 for mobilizing 100 billion dollars
per annum by 2020 have still not been
realized they need to be enhanced given
the increased frequency and intensity of
climate extreme events thought a global
climate Risk Index of all parties of the
UNF CCC must be created under the
auspices of the U.N system
projects from the most vulnerable
countries on this index must get
prioritized and Speedy approvals for
climate Finance
and finally mitigation ambition needs to
be revived in a clear
burden share formula
the province of common but
differentiated responsibilities must be
respected as we race towards a much
higher trajectory of warming
than defined in the Paris agreement
Pakistan's 2030 ambition in the indices
are already higher than many countries
but we understand our responsibilities
as we move towards a net zero plan once
we recover
accent is
unless there is a transformational shift
in the flow of capacities finance and
technology that reverses the Pyramid of
climate Capital the bargain between the
North and the South will not work
I want to share something with you
while
we were grappling
and fighting against us
torrential floods which hit Pakistan
very severely
we had to import
wheat
palm oil
and of course
very expensive
oil and gas
spending
a roundabout
30 32 billion dollars
to finance its import
on the other
we have repurposed
redirected
or meager resources
to meet the basic needs of millions of
households affected by these
devastating floods
we had to
dish out about 316 million dollars
through a program by the name of
Income Support Program
to provide
an amount of
113 dollars per household
to about 3 million households in flood
affected areas
and now
winter is setting in
and we need to provide
shelter homes
medical treatment
and food package to these millions of
people in
different provinces of Pakistan
for which
we are spending
billions of rupees
from our own Mega resources
now imagine
ladies and gentlemen
on one hand
we have to
cater for our food security for the
Common Man
by spending billions of dollars
and on the other
we have to spend
billions of dollars
to protect
flood affected people from further
miseries
and difficulties
how on Earth can one expect from us that
we will undertake this gigantic task
on our own
of course we are thankful to
International Community
for helping us in this difficult time
coming to a rescue
through donations and through
stuff which have been shipped through
air Freights and of course through sea
routes
but the gap
is humongous the Gap is widening by the
day
therefore
it is
the duty and responsibility
of global North to understand
our difficulties in our plight
we wouldn't want
that tomorrow God forbid some other
country
should become victim of this
climate induced disaster and I call it
man-made disaster
it is extremely important
that if we have to fight and rebuild
and repair our infrastructure
which is which has to be resilient
and adaptive
then of course we
can only do through
additional funding
not through additional loans and debts
because this would be a financial death
trap
I hope this conference
well not only
listen to this message
loud and clear but convey
just to all
who have the power and Financial Muscle
to change the course of history
loud and clear and that is what this
conference is meant for
ladies and gentlemen it is now or never
for us there is indeed no Planet B I
thank you for your patience God bless
you thank you for your Excellency
[Applause]
foreign
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr John Oscar star prime
minister of Norway
your Excellency you have the flow
thank you Mr President
well this cup is all about
urgent action that is needed to keep the
1.5 Target alive and consequently Norway
is stepping up its efforts
I am pleased to announce that we have
submitted an enhanced climate Target
under the Paris agreement
we will reduce emission by at least 55
by 2030 compared to 1990 levels
we will deliver on our commitments
we will Implement a just climate policy
by increasing our carbon tax to 200
Euros per ton by 2030. we will cut
emissions
and create jobs we will align our
policies and targets
by making an annual climate action plan
as part of our national budget
we will fulfill our pledge to double
climate Finance within the next four
years
Mr President the livelihoods of millions
of poor and vulnerable people are
threatened by the loss of Nature and the
impacts of climate change the two are
interlinked
this is why Norway is committed to
tripling its adaptation Finance with the
particular emphasis on Africa
we also need to strengthen efforts to
prevent loss and damage
and we must ensure that no one is Left
Behind
this cup is about implementation
in every possible way to help cut
emissions build resilience and make a
leap forward towards more renewable
energy
important initiatives are launched
at Glasgow and again here at charm
milkshake
I am pleased to be part of the global
energy Alliance for people and planets
this initiative will accelerate and
scale up Equitable energy transitions
financing supporting
renewable energy projects ready to take
off providing opportunities for decent
jobs and energy access to one billion
people in developing countries
climate change and biodiversity laws
must be addressed together Mr President
Norway is determined to cooperate with
tropical forest countries that are
working to reduce deforestation and we
have made a number of initiatives
public at this conference
as a further reiterated
at this cop I applaud president-elect
Lula's renewed commitment to the Amazon
Mr President the oceans are also an
important part of the solution
the ocean panel has highlighted the huge
potential of ocean-based climate action
to reduce emissions
the green shipping in his challenge was
launched yesterday with the aim of
reducing emissions from this important
sector
this initiatives carries hopes
new industrial Solutions hold also
promise for the future this afternoon
president El sisi and I launched the
initial phase of an integrated green
hydrogen production facility the first
of its kind in an emerging market
the facility will use solar energy to
produce hydrogen an illustration of
Africa's vast potential to harness
renewable energy
and I'm proud that the Norwegian
companies Caltech is spearheading this
project along with Egyptian partners
friends Mr President and Mission Cuts
adaptation efforts nature-based
Solutions and advances in technology
gives ground to Hope
there are reason to be deeply concerned
but we must never lose hope so let's
work together to move faster on ambition
and implementation thank you Mr
President
thank you for your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
Her Excellency Miss najla Bodin M Rondon
prime minister of Tunisia
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you Mr President
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr cleopas Seafood lebani
prime minister of eslatani
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you
Mr President
heads of state and government
Secretary General of the United Nations
distinguish delicates
it is a great honor for me to present
this statement on behalf of the head of
state of the kingdom of eswatini his
majesty kingdoms what is the third and
this Focus Gathering
Mr President
allow me to congratulate the government
of the Republic of Egypt for the
excellent task of ensuring That We
Gather here
in this beautiful city of El Sheikh and
with a Clear Vision for implementation
Mr President
we come
with great expectations and encouraged
by our leadership by your leadership in
searching the theme of this scope so
that to that of implementation
we have seen escalating impacts of
climate change
despite all the meetings agreements and
commitments we have made over the past
30 years
of negotiation under the U.N fccc
it is time our actions match our ways
unfortunately
we have already lost a lot of time with
great disappointment
observe some developed countries not
only failing to provide the promise U.S
dollar 1 billion
per year but also swing back to fossil
fuels despite the classical Pact
failing to reduce greenhouse gas
emission is setting the Earth on
accelerated path of loss and damage
which is hard to reverse
we have come to the point where the
agency to mitigate and adapt is being
overshadowed by the need to deal
with the loss and damage we are already
facing and experiencing hence the need
for a loss and damage
financing facility
foreign
we are happy
though that the issue of loss and damage
is now part of our discussion
we can no longer afford to reduce the
need for the facility dialogue and it is
financed and its financing should be
additional to that of adaptation and
mitigation
Mr President
we are at the beginning of our rain fall
season
yet we still have not recovered from the
last year's Seasons disaster impacts
which left our people dead
others homeless and unprecedented damage
to infrastructure which also affected
the trunk the country's economic
activity
this calls for immediate action
especially with respect to building
resilience and support for responding to
the different losses and damages
finally Mr President
if we are to achieve our climate
ambition leading to the
net zero emissions we must leave no one
behind
we believe it is time to consider how we
can afford Taiwan an opportunity to
contribute to the globe to the global
vision of not zero emissions and two is
part in the global fights against
climate damage against climate change
calls for the unfccc to support taiwan's
professional pragmatic and constructive
participation in the UN
Forum convention for climate change the
price agreement and Associated
mechanisms
I thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Xavier betel
prime minister of Luxembourg
your Excellency you have the floor
um
the problem
is foreign
director
is
social foreign
regular
appear
um
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
Universal
um
foreign
president
foreign
development
news
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency
Mr Sean Mikhail lukundi prime minister
of the Democratic Republic of the Congo
your Excellency you have the floor
merci
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
also Popo
doesn't
play
this is
important
is
supando
the contexter international decrease
or repercussions
like his energetic
the mission of the deoxy the carbona
the pleasure payee industrialism
the responsibility
is collective
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
there's a chance see
acceleration
president
the results
foreign clima
sign
the carbon
je Nepal donkey unifier
a Glasgow
United
Congo
capacity the absorption the carbon
Humanity
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thematic
foreign
foreign
foreign
perspective
the revenue
he should have said to exploitation
the no population
is
foreign
on exoto La presentation
you know this is
particularly the series climatic
o
thank you
the mobilization is
Caesar
the future
Mercy
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Pierre the true prime
minister of Monaco
foreign
for like excellent organizations
immense
is executive
said conference
on Earth
the negotiations
foreign
degree
is opportunities
ecosystem Department
foreign
vlab
California
is
foreign
Enterprise
services
foreign
America
is
foreign
primordial
vulnerable
attributions
the population
is
humanist regulatory
is Arctic
spree
seats is
adaptation
is
foreign
May them miss you
the community careful
is
Ma
Egypt
civilization take Second Street
grass and engineers
adaptations
Revolution
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr savior export Zamora prime
minister of Andorra
your Excellency you have the floor
foreign
foreign
climatic extreme
honestly is
situation
climatic
Department
Avenue
is University
results
foreign
foreign
protection
the person is
adaptation the solution Technologies the
solution from the solar energy foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to overcome
Excellency Miss Mia Amor Motley prime
minister of the vedos
[Applause]
your excellencies you have the floor
thank you very much your excellencies
it is perhaps appropriate that to solve
the greatest challenge facing modern
Humanity
we should come to Egypt the ancient
cradle of civilization human
civilization
so the place where innovation of a
people calls the pyramids to raise and
stand for Generations as a symbol of
what Humanity can accomplish
and who sense
permitted modern
man came to look at the mummified faces
of history and through them better
understand its lessons
address and claim it impacts is critical
for my country
and I've spoken now earlier yesterday
and last year
and the reality is that it continues to
be a matter that engulfs all aspects of
our government
we have indicated that we can only do it
if we have the appropriate policy
framework both domestically and
internationally
and regrettably we continue to fight
these battles to ensure that the
commitments which we make do not remain
on a shelf but can be delivered to our
people and can be delivered for the
benefit of our civilization as Humanity
Barbados has embarked on a roof to reefs
program that allows us to be able to
improve the living conditions the
terrestrial and marine ecosystems and to
transform multiple sectors including
water
agriculture housing energy transport and
waste to support our development and to
build the resilience of our people
we believe that this is absolutely
critical because only a holistic
approach can in fact allow us to retain
our development trajectory rather than
to become victims in ways that we have
purely because we have not built up the
capacity
equally we've embarked on new
initiatives to open the fiscal space
necessary
to achieve our development and our
climate goals within the last three
months we assumed for the first time
blue bonds and those blue bonds
effectively will allow us through the
interest savings with the repurchasing
of our debt with the support of the
inter-american development bank and
indeed the support of The Nature
Conservancy to use the interest savings
over 15 years approximately 50 million
U.S to be able to do for our marine area
that which would otherwise fall purely
on the Consolidated fund that 50 million
U.S will help to finance a marine
conservation trust and we do so because
our Maritime jurisdiction is 424 times
that of our terrestrial environment
similarly those blue bonds for the first
time introduced pandemic Clauses
recognizing that one of the difficulties
that we face
is that we were unable to be able to
finance our development easily while at
the same time paying interest rates
paying interest for debt as a result of
the pressures with respect to the
pandemic if we can through our different
our natural disaster Clauses and our
pandemic Clauses provide for that relief
from the payment of debt while Meeting
those crises that face our people then
it gives us the fiscal space that would
otherwise not be available
similarly we are working on the
establishment of a blue-green investment
facility not just for Barbados but for
the Eastern and Southern Caribbean
because we need to have dedicated
financing that is Affordable if we are
to pursue the adaptation that is
inevitable given the trajectory of where
we are going with the climate
my friends much has been said as well
about the Bridgetown initiative which is
intended to ensure access to
concessional funding for middle-income
countries that have been effectively
graduated from the World Bank
and to be able to benefit from the new
resilience and sustainability trusts
which the international monetary fund
has created that will give us the
opportunity to have access to 20-year
money with a 10 and a half year
moratorium and at interest rates that
are compatible with what we have to do
to make ourselves more resilient
we also believe that the other aspects
of the Bridgetown initiative will
benefit countries far beyond small
island developing States because in this
the reality is that unless our financial
institutions can speak to the current
realities they will not be able to help
us transition in this new way
the Wipeout events that are are at risk
for us
as small states become a serious concern
we make the point all the time that
large countries can
be the subject of a climatic event and
still survive small states do not have
that luxury and for many of us the risk
of a white boat event is simply too
great for us to carry
historically the Human family has
confronted every Threat by finding
appropriate Solutions
we believe it is entirely within our
Province and capacity to so do again the
truth is we have come to Sharma Sheikh
the city of peace
to ensure that we come and Advance the
needs of humanity to protect ourselves
to protect our lives to protect our
livelihoods as a human race
but let us leave this city of Peace
committed
to ensuring that on this journey we have
added to it
the addition of loss and damage on the
agenda is a significant achievement and
one that we have been fighting for for
many years
we will not achieve the conclusion of it
but the fact that we have placed it on
the agenda recognizes that those
countries such as ours who have not
contributed greatly to the emission of
greenhouse gases should not be crowded
out our fiscal space in order to be able
to finance the reconstruction after a
climatic event and should not be chosen
between the financing of education and
health or reconstruction of our
societies I do believe that we have
immoral and just cause and it is up to
us to work together to ensure that
this effort and this journey will Define
us and Define what is possible for the
survival of the human race and for the
protection of our planet I am obliged to
you your excellencies thank you
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Saleh kebzabo
prime minister of Chad
your Excellency you have the floor
conference
to protocol observey
Starbucks
on the purple edu government Richard
s
the conference Department
Egypt
Atlanta
foreign
we'll see
Tribune
address
International
foreign
desert
so an economy proposes agriculture
the resources
later the vulnerability actually feature
the child
sectors climatic
the principal consequence do said
vulnerabilitation
natural
poverty
the degradations
the plan do
aerial development the space and visions
Corolla
National
League terrorists
vulnerability particular this is
ecosystem
it is a community
initiative pertinence
foreign
adaptation
is
a contribution determination
foreign
climatic
the finalization the plan National
adaptations
YouTube
foreign
foreign
the program it is action Visa approaches
foreign
fossil
asila said
abusive the transport is international
Progressive degrees
foreign
importation
is
[Music]
necessary
is
many times they miss you share
participant
is
Congo
this is
the population
and term the contribution the child
alike Libre ecologic Mondial
is
the depression the bodily situated
download
contribution
La foreign
foreign
a necessary
conferencing
Miracle ecology person
is
climatic
don't the grounder
foreign
I found the fair first problems actually
composed to say phenomenon
who see
allergies
foreign
population
foreign
foreign foreign
Mercy
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency can of drive my God
prime minister of Maori
Your Excellence is you have the floor
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
climatic
and the Zone do not revealability
particularly or plant climatic
Environmental ecologic
Ally said
the music planet
foreign
foreign
the population
foreign
[Music]
Republic
social
program presidency
the construction of the design trees the
forage
[Music]
National
s population
is
foreign
Trump
purity
the presidential transitions
the minister of inaugural decision
adaptation
the population
is
foreign
economy
foreign
than to do Palace
foreign
[Music]
module
Global the transition equitable
prosperion development
of benefits exclusive the population was
affected
the temperature is
[Music]
foreign
foreign
climatic
Humanity
participant
is
leadership
foreign
concrete
dollar freak particularly and
development
residence effective the community
first the transformation
address
convince you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
could you solve natural planet
could you preserve a Humanity not true
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
this brings us to the end of our
national statements for today
distinguishers of state and government
delegates honored guests the opening of
the second part of the eye level segment
will be held on Tuesday 15th November at
10 hours in this plenary
with this I declare this joint meeting
of the Corp the CMP and the cmware
adjourned
a distinguished delegates honored guests
have the pleasure to invite
our Excellency Miss na kyung won special
presidential Envoy for climate and
environment of the Republic of Korea
his Excellency Mr Ji Jenkins
president of
Japan's special representative and
China's special Envoy for climate change
his Excellency Mr bolognski
president of Ukraine through a video to
deliver special messages to the plenary
I now invite Her Excellency Miss na King
Warren special presidential Envoy for
climate and environment of the Republic
of Korea to deliver her statement
Excellency you have the floor
foreign
good afternoon
it is a great pleasure for me to attend
the cop again
in seven years
do you know what the world of 2020 is
the Collins Dictionary shows Palma
crisis
it refers to a never-ending cycle of
crisis
climate change of course is a part of
the Palmer crisis together with kovid
and political and economic instability
we need to walk to to cope with the
Palmer crisis
climate change needs to be addressed by
all together
regardless of political orientation
economic standing age or geographical
background
climate change is a matter of life and
Lively food
it is also it is it is a matter of the
very existence for all of us it is also
a matter of making a living for all of
us
whether we end our future generation can
survive whether we can live well all
depends on what we do today and what we
do together
the cop 27 should be an implementation
cup
this cup should be an event where we can
make tangible progress in translating
our commitments into actions
we need to agree on the mitigation work
program so that we can implement the
program beginning next year
we also need progress in the global goal
on adaptation
I sincerely hope we can meet the 100
billion US dollar Target for climate
Finance is less possible and agree on
the new Collective Quantified goal for
climate Finance
after his inauguration in May president
Jun
declared our foreign policy Vision as a
global pivotal state
addressing the climate crisis is one of
Korea's top foreign policy agendas
we are truly committed to fulfilling our
law as a responsible member of the
International Community
Korea will scale up its green Oda to
help developing countries transition to
a low carbon future and share its
innovative green green technologies with
the entire Humanity
last year our former president announced
Korea's NDC of 40 percent emissions
reduction from the 2018 level by 2030.
this NDC is very challenging
in order to deliver on our NDC by 2030
Korea will have to achieve a minimum
four percent emissions reduction
annually
however our new president Yoon of formed
this NDC showing his strong will to step
up our efforts to tackle climate change
my president confirmed that the Republic
of Korea would walk toward this target
based on science and innovation
under the strategy for carbon neutrality
and green growth the Korean government
will pursue
responsible implementation on orderly
transition
carbon neutrality and green growth
driven by by innovation
many Korean companies already have the
world-class Technologies in battery and
ESS
the Korean government will select the
100 core Technologies for carbon
neutrality to support the Green Tech
Innovation we also aim to achieve a
balanced Energy Mix by increasing the
share of both nuclear power and
renewable energy
we are also accelerate green hydrogen
energy development
colleagues the theme of the 2013
pyeongchang winter Special Olympics that
I shared
was together we can I think this was
hold meanings for our climate action as
well I believe the global response to
Climate Change Is Possible only when
developed countries and developing
countries work together
in order to appear the stronger trust
between developed and developing
countries technology finance and
capability building to support
developing countries are key
Korea has been a rare example to become
a leading economy from a world-torn poor
economy we fully understand the
importance of Oda for developing
countries and that's why we plan to
increase the green Oda to support their
green transition
the Republic of Korea will not only
increase the green Oda amount for
developing countries but also actively
engage in technological cooperation
we will also continue to step up the
support for the GCF and gggi located in
Korea
the second replenishment of the
GCF will continue until next year as you
already know the GCF will play a
critical role in strengthening
cooperation between developed and
developing countries
let's continue our strong support for
the GCF you agree right
last but not least I would like to tell
you something about 2030 World Expo that
boost of Korea aims to host
the ocean offers a solution of fresh
Avenue to tackle climate change
Korea's beautiful Port City and the
world's second largest treasurement port
Busan will present
a vision for tackling climate change
through the World Expo with an also
known for producing K movies will add
more fun to the World Expo
dear colleagues
actions speak louder than words now it's
time to implement our climate action and
remember together we can overcome the
climate crisis
developed and developing countries
together
governments and the Civil Society
together the old and the young together
the conservatives and the progressives
together let's go together together we
can thank you
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
I now invite his Excellency Mr G General
president XI Japan's special
representative and China's special Envoy
for climate change to deliver his
statement
your excellencies you have the floor
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
commodity
foreign
foreign
already our Union
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
[Applause]
I now invite the plenary to listen to
the video message from his Excellency Mr
volunteer zelinski president of Ukraine
dear colleagues Dear Mr President Abdel
fatah al-sizim ladies and gentlemen at
this conference like at other Summits
and high-level meetings on catastrophic
climate change there is no lack of Wars
there is no lack of good definitions and
no shortage of prescriptions for what
the world should do I listened to some
of the speeches today and I agree with
many of the assessments the world is on
the brink and Beyond this limit
devastating changes that will forever
change the usual life on all continents
colleagues have described well what this
means no one can stay aside and the
poorer the person
the poorer the family the poorer the
country the more painful the effects of
climate change will be for them
however this also applies to all rich
Nations it is impossible to buy off the
destruction of the climate but why do we
keep talking about it every year
why instead of reports on what has been
done the same forecasts and appeals are
made every year
I will be honest there are still many
who do not take the climate agenda
seriously and not only in politics but
also in big business
there are still many for whom climate
change is just rhetoric or marketing or
political ritual whatever but not real
action
they are the ones who hamper the
implementation of climate goals they are
the ones in their offices who make fun
of those who fight to save life on the
planet although in public they seem to
support the work for the sake of nature
in every possible way
they are the ones who start wars of
aggression when the plan cannot afford a
single gunshot because it needs Global
joint actions
you all know about the war that Russia
started in Europe trying to destroy the
independence of my country but what does
this war mean
this Russian war has brought about an
energy crisis that has forced dozens of
countries to resume coal-fired power
generation in order to lower energy
prices for their people at least a
little to lower prices that are
shockingly rising due to deliberate
Russian actions the Russian war brought
an acute food crisis to the world which
hit worse those countries suffering from
the existing manifestations of climate
change catastrophic droughts large-scale
floods the Russian war destroyed five
million Acres of forests in Ukraine in
less than six months not every country
in the world has such an area of forests
that we have brought in Ukraine by
Russian shelling
we have to check every day this
situation at the Parisian nuclear power
plant the largest in Europe
if there is no radiation leaks the
Russian army has turned this nuclear
power plant the factor in their military
training ground
they are constantly playing with
connecting and disconnecting their plant
and nuclear reactors from their power
grid there is a directories of a
radiation disaster who will care for
example about the amount of the
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere is
part of Europe or the middle is and
possibly Northern Africa God forbid are
covered by a radiation Cloud after an
accident in the Parisian
last year we couldn't even imagine that
kind of question but this year Russia
has paused dozens of such questions to
the world
ladies and gentlemen
world needs honesty we must tell those
who do not take the climate agenda
seriously that they are making a
catastrophic mistake
we must stop those who with their insane
and illegal War are destroying the
world's ability to work United for a
common goal
there can be no effective climate policy
without the peace on the earth because
in fact nations are thinking only about
how to protect themselves Here and Now
from the threats created in particular
by their Russian aggression
Russia needs to shut the guns and hide
its missiles so the wall finally hears
what we can all really do together to
save ourselves from the climate disaster
all of us in Europe Africa Asia America
Australia I invite you
you all to support our initiative
presented here at the conference
creation of a global platform to assess
the impact of military actions on
climate and environment we are all
thinking about how to generate hundreds
of billions of dollars to help
developing countries protect themselves
from the climate change
under these conditions how can anyone
cause additional insane damage to the
nature with their invasive military
ambitions
such Ambitions deserve only punishment
Mr President to visit said an important
thing in his speech we must meet
expectations of the people all over the
world people who are suffering more than
ever I absolutely support this goal we
must ensure that suffering doesn't
multiply because the wall doesn't have
time to respond to climate challenges
but to do this we need joint effective
actions and for them to be we need peace
and I thank everyone who works for peace
I thank everyone who takes seriously the
need to protect life on the earth for
the benefit of all people all nations
all classes all cultures
I thank you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we thank his Excellency the president of
Ukraine for his message
thank you delegates
this marks the end of the messages
foreign
[Music]